[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisir ravi de vous retrouver pour de
nouvelles cd sorti le sommaire de ce
jeudi 7 février pour cette année
d'anniversaires laurent ball train lance
une série de nouvelles animations de la
bb visite à la soirée vins et fromages
solène congrès sera avec nous pour nous
présenter le programme
la ludothèque de montigny le bretonneux
a fait peau neuve nouveau jeu de
nouvelles salles les enfants ont de quoi
s'amuser avec leurs parents reportage
dans ce numéro le quatrième 31 des voix
c'est ce samedi longue de candidats
s'affronteront sur la scène de la maison
de l'environnement de malgré un mot le
public pourra choisir son favori
après plusieurs mois de travaux la
ludothèque de montigny le bretonneux
reprend du service
un espace plus grand et nouvelle salle
dédiée aux enfants de 6 mois à 3 ans
nous avons découvert des nouvelles
couleurs ses nouvelles couleurs lors de
son inauguration mercredi 6 février
[Musique]
avec de nouveaux jeux et de nouveaux
espaces la ludothèque je tu ils de
montigny le bretonneux reprend du
service pour les enfants ce qu'on va se
connecter avec cette espace tel pour la
réaménager ses tableaux river la
relation parent enfant pour que les
parents jouent vraiment avec leurs
enfants et non pas une peau un endroit
où les enfants se débrouillerait comme
ça c'est vraiment la partie nouveauté de
cette année
oui j'aime beaucoup il ya plein de jeux
à disposition du coup il ya plus de jeu
qu'à la maison
donc ça leur plaît en plus de cet espace
éveil pour les six mois à trois ans la
ludothèque bénéficie d'une grande salle
supplémentaire pour favoriser de
nouvelles animations comme les ateliers
d'initiation à la robotique
j'ai fait un circuit à mentir en mots
qui va suivre le circuit
mais il ya des codes de couleurs il
fallait rénover cette ludothèque
tout simplement parce que c'est un
équipement qui avait 30 ans 30 ans dont
com ou 30 ans d'une part l'équipe en
avait beaucoup vieilli et puis de
l'autre les besoins ont aussi évolué
l'accès est libre du mardi au samedi
pour les adhérents ils peuvent même
emprunter des jeux pour un euro en 1984
deux passionnés de chemin de fer et
grand collectionneur de petit train
ouvrez le rambo litres un an musée
unique avec plus de 4000 pièces qui fête
cette année ses 35 ans avec nous un
plateau solène londres et vous êtes
chargé d'accueil de médiation rambo
litres un bon jour alors 35 ans que le
musée présente les trains des 19 et
20ème siècles un lieu phare de
rambouillet oui plutôt
déjà ces deux passionnés qui ont comme
vous l'avez dit ouvert le musée il ya 35
ans messieurs jacques visbecq qui était
collectionneur privé et qui a fait don
de sa collection et de sa maison pour
construire le musée à la ville de
rambouillet et monsieur alain badie qui
travaille toujours au musée qui était
modélistes et enfin de talent et
passionné aussi dans les trains et
c'était une volonté politique énorme de
la ville de rambouillet d'avoir un
patrimoine autre que historiques et
naturels comme la forêt de rambouillet
où le château d'avoir un musée
voilà qui est assez atypique de par sa
collection
et cette année vous avez décidé de le
bouger un peu vous développez de
nouvelles animations
c'est ça on a voulu on veut pardon
attirer un public qui se renouvellent
souvent mais qui a besoin d'être un peu
on va dire plus jeunes et modernisé donc
on a décidé de faire des bébés visite
par exemple entre entre autres
animations
donc les babys visite c'est pendant 30
minutes vous venez avec votre enfant il
ya un éveil musical corporelle
et artistiques au sein du musée de la
collection big baby lise et c'est
vraiment très très très jeune ses rides
entre 18 mois et moins de 3 ans donc
c'est vraiment amener le tout petit à
découvrir un musée un cadre culturel et
les parents avec pour partager un moment
familial un peu particulier du coup vous
avez d'autres rendez-vous les pauses
déjeuner les visites pause déjeuner
c'est le midi pour les personnes qui
travaillent sur rambouillet ou qui ne
travaillent pas et qui ont envie de
changer leur repas du midi
donc c'est une visite expresse du musée
thématiques
c'est une fois tous les deux mois on a
aussi pour les plus grands les visites
guidées mensuel donc c'est une visite
guidée d'une heure et à la fin on a eu
bien sûr une donc vous découvrez la
collection les un siècle de trains jouer
le réseau maquette au second étage avec
400 mètres de voie et une petite
animation vapeur nous montrer comment
être un jouet fonctionne avec la vapeur
et ça ça marche à tous les coups même
pendant les vacances et pour les
vacances on a des animations aussi pour
les emplois d'avenir celle entre les
vacances scolaires dans une semaine deux
semaines même lorsque vous avez des
surprises pour ses vacances
c'est ça on a quelques surprises on
avait vu qu'il y avait souvent comme je
l'avais dit des enfants avec leurs
grands-parents grande majorité qui
revenait au musée qui avait déjà fait
les livres et d'activités qui sont très
bien faits
mais bon voilà c'est un peu répétitif
pour eux et donc on s'est dit que pour
chaque vacances on créerait des nouveaux
jeux donc il ya des cluedo s'est basé
sur le thème du cluedo le chasse aux
trésors des jeux de piste un jeu de noël
particulier il ya aussi des animations
donc basé sur des thèmes la science dans
les trains par exemple là ça va être les
secrets cachés d'être un jouet on a eu
des cortons train de noël pour les
vacances de noël
voilà six ans que j'avais vraiment
développé pour chaque public son
animation ça on a encore beaucoup à
développer pour un autre public qui et
les adolescents parce que c'est ce qui
manque un peu au musée que les
adolescents viennent et pour les trois
entre les 3 et les six ans bien sûr
développer pas une baby visées du coup
mais autre chose c'est un des projets
qu'on a pour l'an prochain parce que on
parle de 35 ans c'est l'anniversaire du
musée forcément mais ses visites fins et
animations pardon vont être renouvelés
les années prochaines
en fait c'est vraiment une volonté qu'on
a eue avec la directrice de de
redynamiser le musée le dépoussiérer un
peu comme on a tendance à nous mêmes
toujours pour le dépoussiérer comme vous
dites vous avez aussi développer des
partenariats au fait des journées jeux
de société par exemple
voilà le prochain c'est le 13 février on
organise avec marlène de l'association
waka waka
une journée jeux de société donc les
gens viennent au musée et pendant leur
visite ils peuvent découvrir des jeux
pour tout âge on a aussi une soirée
train et jeux de société
donc ça c'est le 1 vendredi soir au mois
de mars où avec tisane les petites
sucreries ont fait des jeux sur le thème
du train toujours on reste dans le thème
est
voilà donc sa part c'est pour les plus
grands quand même parce que ça dure un
peu longtemps mais c'est à partir de 8
ans donc ça attire quand même un public
qu'on n'a pas souvent
donc pour tout découvrir sur les trains
en s'amusant on peut aller au
rambolitains merci sol à madrid est venu
sur notre plateau vous pouvez retrouver
toutes les informations sur le musée et
ses prochaines animations sur le site
internet du site puisque l'on est à
rambouillet profitez-en pour faire un
tour à l'espace rambouillet après
hibernation ses portes sont de nouveau
ouverts depuis le 5 février la salle de
réception rénové permettra de nouveaux
ateliers pédagogiques et la volerie
accueillera une nouvelle espèce un
vautour percnoptère le réseau de
médiathèques
au fil des pages 78 organise son 7e jeu
d'écriture pour les enfants
arc-en-ciel chaussettes tournicoter vous
devez choisir cinq mots parmi la liste
est envoyé à votre rédaction du genre
littéraire que vous souhaitez jusqu'au
22 février
le rendez vous des artistes amateurs de
la région spécialité peintures
sculptures et photos débute ce samedi 9
février
la 34e édition du mot repartent met
cette année à l'honneur jérôme cherrier
un photographe norvégien
le salon se déroule jusqu'au 22 février
à l'espace albert camus kirikou à 20 ans
pour l'occasion le cinéma elle
attrape vous proposons ce classique du
cinéma d'animation
quel pin au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
nous connaissons tous kirikou
aujourd'hui il vient d'avoir 20 ans ce
compte est toujours aussi charmant et
humaniste et donc les enfants
d'aujourd'hui doit absolument le
découvrir et les enfants d'hier doivent
absolument le voir ou le revoir sur
grand écran
souvenez vous un peu l'histoire à peine
sorti du ventre de sa mère il parlait
court plus vite que le commun des
mortels mais il est aussi très malin et
il incarne le courage et la persévérance
dans ce film la frontière entre le bien
et le mal n'est pas si évidente mais
c'est ça le message fondamental du film
la source de la méchanceté est bien
souvent la souffrance il ya un retour en
arrière est possible et pour ça il faut
bien sûr aller à la rencontre de l'autre
et le comprendre pour sublimer ce compte
michel ocelot a utilisé le dessin
traditionnel pain sur papier la faune et
la flore y sont très riches
d'ailleurs les décors sont ouvertement
inspiré du douanier rousseau la musique
composée par youssou ndour ce film peut
être vu à partir de 4 ans mais certaines
scènes sont impressionnantes pour les
plus jeunes comme les apparitions
théâtrales de la sorcière ou les animaux
sauvages
je conseille donc ce film pour les
enfants à partir de 5 ans retrouvez
kirikou et la sorcière au cinéma le
grenier à sel
[Musique]
une compétition non pas sportive mais
vocal le tremplin des voix de
l'association la voix en scène de magny
les hameaux revient pour une quatrième
édition d'un deux chanteurs ont été
sélectionnés après une première audition
ils sont coachés par les organisateurs
avant quand l'interprétation de ce
samedi 9 février le public un rôle
majeur ils votent pour son candidat
préféré au final deux vainqueurs le prix
du jury et le prix du public
les coaches ont un rôle important auprès
de candidats audrey benoît responsable
du tremplin était sur le plateau du
cetud culture
l'objectif peu importe le niveau et le
temps qu'ils ont l'expérience qu'ils ont
on va dire c'est de pouvoir les
accompagner sur le chemin dans le chemin
où ils en sont et on va dire justement
pour s'améliorer pour connaître un petit
peu leur donner les clés pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir partager avec le public
pour pouvoir mieux chanter i noté un
changement de salle
initialement annoncées à l'estaminet le
tremplin des voix victime de son succès
aura finalement lieu à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux
retrouvez toutes les informations sur le
site internet pour organiser son
semi-marathon prévue le dimanche 14
avril la ville de trappes recherche des
bénévoles si vous souhaitez assurer
l'accueil le contrôle la sécurité ou le
ravitaillement des coureurs vous pouvez
vous inscrire pour ce deuxième semi
marathon et pour parfaire vos yeux qui
le caractérise de plaisir accueille en
expert national de la discipline pour un
stage spécial sam s'il ne février m
naoki omis sera présent au palais des
sports de 10 heures à 15 heures
promenade issy les moulineaux c'est
votre rubrique sortir en ile de france
[Musique]
le célèbre photographe raymond depardon
met en valeur les monuments clés de la
ville d'issy les moulineaux à travers
une exposition car en photographie
témoin de la métamorphose de la ville de
la petite couronne de paris
reportage de paul vi look et de nos
confrères la grand paris
raymond depardon immortalise
larchitecture d'issy les moulineaux le
célèbre photographe présente au musée de
la carte à jouer quarante photographies
d'une qualité rare donnant presque
l'illusion d'être face à ces bâtiments
construits par de grands architectes
comme jean nouvel
les photographies témoignent de la
métamorphose de la ville d'issy les
moulineaux
il ya quelques années nous avions exposé
une fois une exposition de photographies
de robert doisneau qui montrait une
banlieue humaniste une banlieue encore
industrielle est là aujourd'hui à
travers cette exposition nous souhaitons
montrer aussi une autre notre visage
qu'offre la ville d'issy les moulineaux
le choix était portée vraiment sur
l'innovation architecturale pour montrer
vraiment en quoi la ville s'est
modernisée a beaucoup changé c'est
transformé ces dernières années grâce à
tous ces projets finalement
architecturaux qui ont fait intervenir
deux grands noms jean nouvel christian
de portzamparc parmi d'autres donc
vraiment c'est vraiment de pardon le
regard d'un photographe
une déambulation en ville mais à travers
le prisme de l'architecturé et de
l'innovation architecturale
une salle est entièrement consacré au
travail de raymond depardon
la scénographie épurée de l'exposition
réalisée par l'artiste jean michel
alberola et sa fille met en valeur les
photographies mais des bâtiments d'issy
les moulineaux se retrouve également
dans toutes les salles du musée puisque
l'on retrouve les photographies entre
les collections de cartes à jouer
une exposition accessible pour tous les
publics bien sûr elle s'adresse vraiment
plus grand nombre à la fois les isséens
qui sont qu'ils seront fiers je pense de
voir leur ville sous un autre jour un
petit peu différent parfois méconnus qui
découvre aussi parfois tel ou tel
bâtiment et donc qu'ils vont après faire
une balade en ville pour pouvoir
s'approcher au plus près de ses
bâtiments mais également les parisiens
les personnes en france de manière
générale qui s'intéresse à la
photographie à raymond depardon
et puis qui vont découvrir une nouveau
visage de la ville rendez vous jusqu'au
30 juin prochain pour admirer la
métamorphose d'issy les moulineaux pour
musée de la carte à jouer c'est la fin
de votre set il choisit dire merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous jeudi
prochain en attendant bonne semaine sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
où
[Musique]